hey I'm Jesse welcome back for those
that haven't been tuning in I'm here at
the Wolfram tech conference 2017 just
talking to developers and other
interesting people using our technology
and some really cool ways and today I'm
here with funny ending ly enough I am
here with Jesse so Jesse's gonna tell us
a little bit about what he's doing here
at the woman tech conference
specifically in kind of what he has over
here for us so thanks Jesse so this over
here behind me to my right is a pen
plotter it's in it's a older computer
physical computer output device it
predates the inkjet printer by about 20
20 years and it before the inkjet
printer was introduced it was really the
only efficient and fast way of doing
color printed output like there's like
laser printers but they didn't really do
color back then and so unlike a printer
that you have at home which prints in
terms of raster graphics so like rows
columns and pixels this is a vector
output device so it moves a physical pen
around on the paper so it draws in terms
of points lines and circles so what
you're did this come out exactly it
looks yeah the this particular model the
HP 7550 plotter was introduced in 1984
and was sold for about ten years
I don't know how old this particular
instance of it is but it's around thirty
thirty probably around thirty years ago
yeah so what what exactly is it printing
can you tell me so so I wrote a package
for the Wolfram language that converts
Wolfram language symbolic graphics into
instructions for the plotter that can be
communicated over serial and then as a
layer on top of that sort of as a case
study for that package I made a pen
plotter photo booth so you so you can
have a picture of your face take it and
then there was just a tiny bit of
Wolfram language code that vectorize
does that and then feeds it into my
package which can convert
to the instructions for the pen bladder
nice so like in algorithmically
generated selfie yep exactly
cool so uh can we check out how it works
yeah absolutely you can take your
picture on the iPad over that respect
yes oh or do you do you want to see
something else there oh no no because I
don't go through like the whole yeah
thanks for everyone to watch okay so how
close do I have to be to go oh that's
that's pretty good yeah I took took
another one before this and I looked
like grumpy cat
okay looks great let's print thank so
it'll take about 30 seconds to do the
vectorization maybe a bit more because
the background here is pretty complex
it's running on a Raspberry Pi which
isn't particularly efficient with the
image processing and in Wolfram language
at least not yet so once that dot once
that is done it will it will send those
instructions over over serial to the pen
plotter and it'll start printing right
now it actually has an 8 an 8 pen
carousel so you can use up to 8 pens in
the plotter of different colors and you
can swap between them during during a
plot I'm just using one color which is a
red so when I talked to you yesterday
over at your booth on the other side of
the basement you mentioned that this
uses edge detect can you tell me a
little bit more about that function if
there are improvements that you know of
in the latest 11.2 release for that
function I haven't heard about any
improvements with edge detect I think
it's actually calling an external image
processing library OpenCV so any
improvements hope looks like it's
starting to print you any for any
improvements are gonna be on OpenCV Zen
but edge detect it as the name suggests
it detects edges in the image what it
returns is not it's not in a really good
format it just gives you an image back
where the or it's black and the edges
are highlighted in white so I then use
the function image value positions to
get the positions of all of those white
pixels and then I down sampled out of it
since I don't with the vision of every
single pixel and then there's a really
cool function called find curved path
that breaks that array of pixels into a
set of discrete curves so instead of
having to draw a swan single connected
line it breaks it into a logically
selected set of curves which you can
probably see it printing right now
you'll see you can see it it draws a
curve then it lifts the pan and moves to
the next point and draws another curve
and just keeps doing that and it's
very fast as far as I'm relatively
speaking and it's very bad hi and it is
drawing your collar right now your
collar oh yeah I didn't realize that was
gonna get into the like image the
another one that I took yesterday which
turned out really cool it was able to
get the best I was wearing I mean the
yeah I was wearing a vest a lot yeah
I've noticed about people with plaid
shirts it takes a longer to print them
because it does the whole pattern on the
shirt so drawing your mouth and then
once that's done I have another thing I
can do another case study so some of you
or some of the viewers watching may be
familiar with Wolfram Alpha popular
curves future yeah yes there so there
are hundreds of parametric curves that
are modeled after the faces of famous
people or characters or Pokemon
characters I believe and there you can
access them within the Wolfram language
and you can get a representation of them
as a Wolfram language mesh region so
then what I'm doing since those are
already in the back deform and they're
very high quality I don't do any of that
vectorization that I'm doing with the
with my images from the photo booth so I
can just do a little bit of
transformation on them and send them
right into my my my package and print
them out on the platter so once that's
done I have I believe um do you have a
celebrity you'd like to print well I
would love I know the spot curbs pretty
popular I would love oh wait that's good
here's you well I like the pens starting
to run out yeah it's it's losing ink a
little bit but I would say this is
pretty like good this is not far off
from my usual appearance though I do
think I look a little spooky but I guess
that's just you know it has its own
style its kind of yeah a spooky style
yeah I guess I'll dress like this
character of myself for Halloween here
and here since year
you chose Spock I will start that and
since since it doesn't have to do do the
vectorization you should start on those
immediately yeah I was about to ask you
does it
I'm guessing it's faster at a prince it
doesn't take the pole oh yeah it's
faster different because they've they
like it it's been manually sculpted by
the human so they it's not it's not like
dang any of the background or any
unimportant parts it's just the it's
just the important bits so I'll start
that printing now and it's drying spot
I'm gonna I'm gonna swap out the pan for
my talk later so did you just come up
with this just like in your some of your
spare time to make something fun yeah I
was while I was reading about pen
plotters online and I didn't find any
any blog posts or anything about them
being integrated with the Wolfram
language which is understandable because
it's not exactly a very popular outdated
so but I thought I thought it would be
cool to integrate it with welcome
language is very powerful symbolic
graphics language what are some
improvements if you were to do this
again in the future what would you like
to see implemented like integrated as
far as Wolfram language goes but this
applauding is okay well I there's some
code looks like Spock is done it's
pretty good the Pens the pen the lines
aren't as bad nice
yeah yeah and by myself II was much
coarser yeah these are very smooth yes
very very smooth yes so yes so the there
is some need the all the important stuff
is happening in Wolfram language but
there is some Python code running on the
PI that communicates with the iPad
that's taking the picture over Wi-Fi and
then it's sort of glue code that invokes
the Wolfram language func
and pulls the data back and it actually
does the serial communication because
there was a I was having a bit of a
problem with serial stuff in in Wolfram
language but in the future I learned
about at this conference there's now
functionality for talking to TCP sockets
asynchronous duplex communication on TC
TCP sockets and Wolfram language which I
did not know about before and I'm using
to communicate with the iPad the
WebSocket protocol which is a duplex
asynchronous TCP connection so if I had
known that that was available now in
Wolfram language I probably would have
written that part of it in local
language as well instead of in Python
which I the Python ended up being it's
just stores the pen so it doesn't get
dry so the Python ended up being a
little bit messy and because it's Python
is not very good at doing asynchronous
stuff at all and if you try to ends up
messy so yeah I would I would have done
that in Wolfram language and I would
have the the serial stuff was a little
weird when they hand the handshaking it
uses it does a very cool thing where it
uses handshaking to only accept serial
bytes as it can actually physically draw
them out so there's just a small buffer
there but yeah the handshaking wasn't
working out properly with Wolfram
language so I had to do it in Python so
if I could if I could get that working I
would be able to do this thing except
for the iPad entirely 100% in ice yeah
it seems like you came into like a lot
of view like knowledge here this yes
that's cool um well thanks for taking
the time to talk with me about this and
show our meals like this cool vintage
eighties printer do some really cool
modern stuff so like always a people
question about anything kind of discuss
in this particular segment just leave a
question in the comments we can't get to
it during these live sessions but
someone can get back to you later you
can also go to community Wolfram calm
and pose your own discussions someone
might have already had your questions so
you can check for that too
yeah and thanks for watching